vous avez quelque chose à dire vous à
votre papa ce soir car mon père me
battait match est maintenant non ah bon
pedro non mon pays je laime ça va oui tu
allais mowlem nom ou valérie à mon père
oui c'est avec mon fils l'homme de ma
vie je laime d'anvers et mon papa
moi je veux dire mon père tap tap a fait
tout bien
mais je t'aime très fort franchement je
t'aime très fort ce même site a merdé
sur plein de trucs je t'adore papa je
t'aime très fort ça je n'ai jamais dit
je te le dis là devant la caméra
ne nous demandez pas généré reviens
parce qu'il est mort et à 6 ans jeannie
mignon ça entraîne pas bien ses mots de
champhol ans tient son ambiance assez
d'herbe le meilleur parce que la pole
c'est moi ok ok bon faveur qu'il va tu
sais aussi d'antennes famille c'est nous
c'est cool parce que la première phase
[Applaudissements]
john ani vraiment cool j ai arrêté je
dirais plus le temps passe plus je sais
que c'est toi le meilleur des papas et
je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
ne nous demandez pas d'où elle est
partie mais il est toujours avec moi oui
ah bon c'est bon salaire et les parties
de la série est venu parler mais oui tu
as raison c'est sûr dans sa main moi
j'ai pas grave c'est comme ça
pas dire un truc non simplement le
meilleur papa du monde d'accord merci va
terminer sur 7
[Rires]